[sea shanty music]
♪
♪ I once met a lass so fine
♪ She was drunk on barley wine
♪ I'd been to sea
for months a'three ♪
♪ I knew I could make her mine
♪ And the lass
was past consent ♪
♪ So it was off
with her we went ♪
♪ And we threw her in bed
and rested her head ♪
♪ And we left 'cause
that's what gentlemen do ♪
(all)
♪ A woman has a right
to a drink or two ♪
♪ Without worrying
about what you will do ♪
♪ We say "Yo Ho!"
but we don't say "ho" ♪
♪ 'Cause "ho"
is disrespectful, yo ♪
♪
♪ There once was a girl
from Leeds ♪
♪ Who I heard was good
on her knees ♪
♪ So I docked my ship
for an overnight trip ♪
♪ To take care of all my needs
♪ She was fine
as the tales did tell ♪
♪ And my mast began to swell
♪ So I laid her down
and raised her gown ♪
♪ And performed cunnilingus
for an hour or so ♪
(all)
♪ Always take care
of your lady fair ♪
♪ 'Cause they deserve as much
attention down there ♪
♪ We say "Yo Ho!"
but we don't say "ho" ♪
♪ 'Cause "ho"
is disrespectful, yo ♪
♪
♪ I once had a woman so fair
♪ Whose womb contained my heir
♪ With a son by my side,
the seas we'd ride ♪
♪ The child she would bear
♪ But my girl,
she was no fool ♪
♪ She was working her way
through school ♪
♪ So I did support
when she chose to abort ♪
♪ 'Cause it's her body
and, therefore, her choice ♪
(all)
♪ No, we don't say "booty"
♪ Unless we're talking
'bout gold ♪
♪ We don't look at chests
unless there treasure holds ♪
♪ With a hat,
and a feather ♪
♪ And a cutlass on our hip
♪ We don't ever say "she"
♪ When we're talkin'
about our ship ♪
♪ We don't say "bitch"
and we don't say "whore" ♪
♪ 'Cause that language leads
to things like body dysmorphia ♪
♪ There was a lady
with a golden eye ♪
♪ And the doctor
said she would die ♪
♪ So she emptied her purse
to lift the curse ♪
♪ And prayed to stay alive
♪ She awoke the very next day
♪ And in her grave she lay
♪ But the scariest part
of the story from the start ♪
♪ Is I bet you assumed
the doctor was a man ♪
[all gasping]
(all)
♪ Women are doctors, too
♪ And for a fraction
of doubloons ♪
♪ We say "Yo Ho!"
but we don't say "ho" ♪
♪ 'Cause "ho"
is disrespectful, yo ♪
♪ There was a slut
with tits to here ♪
♪ And an ass like--
[gunshot]
[dramatic music]
♪
♪ 'Cause it's "Yo Ho!"
but we don't say "ho" ♪
(all)
♪ 'Cause "ho" is
♪ Disrespectful, yo
[all cheering]